it takes a lot to be a successful
equestrian patience confidence more
patience and a love for horses my wife
competes in 100 jumpers and this is a
big week in the equestrian world over at
the south point yeah you know a lot
about this this is my world and this is
so cool to learn even more through rocky
she's live at the las vegas national
horse show with more hey rocky how's it
going
hey guys it's going really well i'm just
trying not to get run over here you know
we have nikki here who's one of the
writers of the competition and who is
this guy this is jordan this is java's
miss jordan and she's happy to say hello
to you guys today oh it's a she excuse
me miss jordan i'm so sorry okay
and what are you are you a jumper yep
yeah so we're a jumper so we're here for
the world cup qualifier this week first
time to vegas and really really excited
to be here and hopefully we're going to
have a good week yeah i want you guys to
have a good week too um so my co-host jc
his wife is also a jumper and he says
that she says it takes a lot of patience
in this in this industry what do you
think what does it take to be a jumper
here to be a professional writer in
general i i think it takes exactly that
a lot of patience a lot of hard work and
determination you know you have to deal
with the setbacks there's more highs are
more lows than highs so we have to
appreciate the highs um
take something from every low that we
can make a learning experience try and
find a positive and get up tomorrow with
a can do attitude and try hard again i'm
inspired i like that okay so what is
happening here at the las vegas national
horse show what is that state what are
you fighting for
so this week there's a series of
competitions culminating in the world
cup qualifier on saturday night which is
a
qualifying event for the world cup
finals next spring
so we're here to put the groundwork in
at the beginning of the week try and
settle in try and have a good round in
the grand prix qualifier and then hope
for some luck on saturday night to try
and have double clear and a fast round
yeah and i hear saturday night is going
to be a party there's going to be you
know music drinks food all of that so
bring your whole family you guys can
come on down i mean i see ribbons in the
background over there are you guys
fighting for just ribbons or is there
money here what's going on so there's
money here ribbons are obviously nice
but but the prize purse on saturday
night is a 150 000 class and so we're
fighting for the lion's share of that
what are you going to do with that money
when you win
i think the the running costs of a horse
are you know quite high there every day
with them feeding them caring for them
the labor everything that they all add
up so we try and have a good day to put
some money in the bank to hold us over
for those uh lesser days oh my well good
luck to you i'm so excited for this
entire competition everybody writing
here you guys bring your entire family
down to enjoy at the south point and i
will send it back to you and i hear that
vegas supposed to be a party full stop
so not just saturday night
first time in vegas oh we're gonna we're
gonna help we gotta give them some
pointers on how to party in vegas
thank you rocky we appreciate it yeah
like you said it's not